Kelly Osborne Ozzy Osbourne's daughter
who was just asked why there are no
pictures of her when she was pregnant
and people asked if it was because she
had a surrogate carry her child and
she's denying that I don't know whether
she did or not but she's denying that
she had a surrogate she's saying no I
hid you won't find any pictures of me at
all during pregnancy I hit all nine
months of pregnancy to avoid being fat
shamed because I've been a public figure
all my life and I just didn't want to be
on camera fat I don't know whether that
explanation is true or not it at least
Rings true it at least Rings plausible
that it's it's a little weird in our
culture that pregnancy is shamed that
being a woman being a real woman not
just a pretend man is shamed